on va tout de suite cédé la parole à
louis ou à pascal peu importe sur sur le
buzz
voilà le la meilleure utilisation est en
tous les cas à faire en sorte que les
agriculteurs français qu'ils soient
producteurs de fruits et légumes ou
autres puissent mieux bénéficier des
fonds européens parce que on n'est quand
même pas les premiers de la classe la
sur cet aspect là non plus oui bonjour
merci de m'avoir convient à participer à
vos travaux
alors on a vu tout à l'heure
effectivement toutes les problématiques
et les situations économique
insoutenable auquel on doit faire face
et les agriculteurs de faire face
cerise sur le gâteau en plus à chaque
fois qu'on se déplace dans une
exploitation ou dans la filière la
première question qu'ils nous disent
c'est pourquoi vous dit pas tout les
progrès qu'on a déjà fait tous les
investissements qu'on a déjà fait
pourquoi on ne parle que d'édition sus
pourquoi on n'arrive pas à faire des
consensus
pourquoi et encore hier une émission
hier soir à la télé sur laquelle je ne
reviendrai pas et caractéristiques de ce
que je suis en train de en train de dire
c'est vrai aussi en matière
d'information sur ce qui est fait en
france c'est vrai aussi sur la promotion
de nos produits à l'international
on était le premier exportateur mondial
de pommes il ya quelques années on a
régressé fortement on exportait au moins
une quinzaine de produits en fruits et
en légumes
on est content maintenant presque sur
les doigts d'une main donc globalement
on se dit l'europe a décidé d'aider à la
promotion et à l'information des
produits c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
toujours très présent et là je rejoins
ce que vous avez dit on n'est pas
toujours très présents dans les
instances européennes pour peser et
pourtant quand on y est on obtient
quelques fois de petites choses
alors je prendre puisque vous me
demander d'intervenir pas sur les
interpro jérôme agostini l'euphrate tout
à l'heure mais sur justement cette cet
effort de communication et de promotion
et fait par nos agriculteurs à les
filières on avait obtenu des
parlementaires européens qui le puits se
renforcer justement les communications
collective alors pourquoi m'a simplement
parce que à chaque fois qu'on demande un
effort supplémentaire que ce soit en
matière de bien-être animal
d'environnement quel que soit de
traçabilité d'étiquetage et bien c'est
bien ça augmente le coût des gens et
aucune valeur ajoutée puisque le dis à
personne qu'elle serait lente reprise
qui décideraient d'améliorer ses
produits et qui en même temps déciderait
de le dire à personne
clairement elle disparaît très très vite
c'est exactement ce qui se passe c'est à
dire que à chaque fois qu'une décision
est prise de manière collective publique
en fait nous ne savons pas transformer
cette contrainte aussi légitime soit
elle je pose même pas là cette question
là sauf que on ne le dis à personne et
donc systématiquement à chaque fois
qu'on prend une décision
corrélativement on perd 6% de parts de
marché tant au niveau international que
la part des marchés des produits
français
en france il faut inverser cette
tendance on pensait que le développement
des budgets justement pour faire ça au
niveau européen nous aiderait à faire
cela et les parlementaires d'ailleurs
européen l'avait assez bien compris
malheureusement les actes délégués est
l'exact d'exécution qui sont en train
d'être pris par la commission par le
système administratives sont en train de
saper une grosse partie de ce qu'on
avait obtenu avec l'accord des
parlements repères alors je vais prendre
quand même quelques exemples pour vous
montrer que tout ça c'est pas que du
vent d'ailleurs encore une fois trois
exemples significatifs
d'abord souvent ceux qui parle
d'agriculture n'ont rien à voir avec le
secteur agricole et ça c'est quand même
horripilant jeu une petite pme tout
petit consortium des avionneurs voyez
une grande campagne dont nous avions
pollue moins que les vaches fantastique
quand même alors ça pourrait faire
sourire
mais quand derrière on interroge les
gens il ya des gens que dubawi c'est
peut-être vrai on sait bien les vaches
les rôles assez c'est un peu lui et
c'est donc c'est ça des vraies
conséquences économiques ensuite
deuxième sujet - techniquement je
connais les textes je sais pourquoi il
ya des incohérences sauf que ça devient
inexplicable on s'est battu pour obtenir
l'origine obligatoires notamment dans
les produits frais de l'origine
nationale
quand je dis on s'est battus c'est qu'on
l'a fait de manière volontaire en viande
au départ après la première crise de la
vache folle
48 ans après on était convoqué à la
commission en disant vous avez pas le
droit c'est une entrave aux échanges
intracommunautaires nous on a dit c'est
d'abord une preuve de responsabilité à
la fois des professionnels à dire ce
qu'ils vendent et l'origine des produits
c'est aussi une responsabilité des états
membres puisque le contrôle et dans les
états membres et de vous devriez surtout
nous féliciter de ne pas rendre anonymes
des produits et en plus c'est une
demande de consommateurs
nous avons obtenu dans un certain nombre
de secteurs les frais légumes frais la
viande fraîche effectivement
l'étiquetage de l'origine obligatoires
oui mais y'a hic c'est que la commission
européenne nous interdit en matière de
communication de communiquer sur
l'origine nationale parce qu'une entrave
aux échanges intracommunautaires
potentiel même quand c'est des fonds
strictement interprofessionnelle et je
vous rappelle que nous avons gagné
encore de justice européenne
les fonds interprofessions sont des
fonds professionnels des fonds privés
sont pas des fonds publics
donc vous voyez encore une fois comment
l expliquer à des producteurs qui
contribue à vouloir faire une
communication sur le produit que ils ont
bien et tout la via les coûts sur la
traçabilité sur l'origine mais par
contre collectivement on n'a pas le
droit de communiquer dessus
comment d'un autre côté on va expliquer
aux consommateurs que on a rendu
l'étiquetage obligatoire mais que
collectivement je peux pas le lui dire
voilà ça ce sont des choses je crois que
il va falloir clairement ne pu discuter
là pour le coup excusez moi avec la
commission mais il va falloir leur
imposer
le fait que la mise en avant d origine
nationale n'est pas une entrave aux
échanges entre communautés au contraire
si on veut une fluidité des échanges
il faut donner cette information et
deuxièmement il faut valoriser
économiquement le travail qui est fait
et tous les efforts qui sont faits par
toute une filière est d'abord par les
avait tous merci louis pour ce pour ce
témoignage